I READ IT COVER TO RECOVER.
-- TO COVER.
JOINING US NOW GERALDO RIVERA
AND DR. SEBASTIAN GORKA.
GERALDO, YOU WROTE A GREAT
COLUMN TODAY.
SOMETHING I DON'T WANT TO HAVE
HAPPEN.
I DON'T WANT A CONFRONTATION AT
OUR SOUTHERN BORDER.
SOMEBODY WILL GET HURT OR WORSE
AT THAT BORDER.
IF THEY MAKE IT FROM MEXICO IN
THE CARAVAN, WE HAVE AGREED.
BUILD THE WALL IT WOULD BE GOOD
FOR BOTH SIDES IF IT WAS UP FOR
RIGHT NOW BECAUSE THEY WOULD NOT
BE COMING.
THE PRESIDENT ALREADY GAVE THE
DEAL YOU ARE OFFERING.
HE OFFERED TO MAKE THE
ACCOMMODATION FOR DREAMERS.
NOW PODESTA'S GROUP IS SAYING
DON'T TALK ABOUT IMMIGRATION.
>> IT'S IMPOSSIBLE TO TALK ABOUT
THE CARAVAN OR ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS WITH 2 WEEKS TO GO
BEFORE THIS WHITE-HOT MID-TERM
ELECTION.
IT'S IMPOSSIBLE TO BE RATIONAL
ABOUT THIS.
THIS IS NOT ABOUT MS-13.
THIS IS NOT ABOUT MIDDLE EAST
ERIN MCPIKES.
-- MIDDLE EASTERNERS.
YOU DON'T KNOW ONE PERSON IN
THAT CAWED.
-- CROWD.
IT WOULD BE EASY TO FIND MS-13.
THE PROBLEM IS YOU HAVE
THOUSANDS AND THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE DESPERATE TO IMPROVE
THEIR LOT IN LIFE.
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING].
>> Sean: WE WON'T LET THEM IN.
NOT THIS WAY.
>> WE HAVE A SOVEREIGNTY AND
BORDER ISSUE HERE.
>> ARE YOU GOING TO SHOOT THEM,
SEAN?
>> Sean: NO.
THEY NEED TO BE STOPPED IN
MEXICO.
ARE YOU GOING TO JUST SAY COME
ON IN AND NEVER VET THEM?
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING].
>> THIS IS REALLY BENEATH YOU.
GERALDO.
>> DON'T GIVE ME THAT BENEATH ME
STUFF!
>> GERALDO, I AM AN IMMIGRANT.
OKAY IN IS IMPORTANT TO ME AS
MUCH AS IT IS TO YOU.
TO WRITE AN ARTICLE AND COME ON
SEAN'S SAY AND SAY WHERE YOU
GOING TO SHOOT THEM?
THAT'S UNAMERICAN.
WE DON'T SAY STUFF LIKE THAT.
THIS IS NOT A DICTATORSHIP.
YOU CAN'T MAKE STATEMENTS.
>> WHAT DOES THE MILITARY DO?
>> WHAT THEY HAVE DONE FOR
HURRICANE VICTIMS AND DOING IN
SUPPORT OF THE POLICE WHENEVER
THERE IS RIOTING.
IT'S BEEN DONE FOR 200 YEARS.
OPEN A HISTORY BOOK.
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING].
>> SARAH CARTER IDENTIFIED MS-13
MEMBERS IN THE CARAVAN.
>> DO YOU THINK MS-13 --
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING].
>> GERALDO, THE PRESIDENT OF
GUATEMALA SAID 100 ISIS
MEMBERS --
>> WE NEED REASONS.
WE NEED PATIENCE.
WE NEED COMPASSION.
>> IF THEY ARE INCAPABLE OF
DOING IT, WE WILL PUT THE SAFETY
OF AMERICANS IN THE HANDS OF
MEXICO?
NO.
>> YOU CUT OFF THE AID TO
HONDURAS AND GUATEMALA.
YOU CREATED THOUSANDS AND
THOUSANDS OF DISPLACED PEOPLE.
>> NOBODY HAS A RIGHT TO COME TO
AMERICA.
>> NOBODY HAS THE RIGHT TO COME
TO AMERICA?
>> NO.
NOBODY!
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING].
>> Sean: WE CAN'T LET THE PEOPLE
RUSH OUR BORDERS AND DO NOTHING.
THAT'S INSANITY.
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING].
>> WE DON'T KNOW EVERYBODY IN
THAT CROWD.
YOU CAN'T VOUCH FOR THEM.